we all have things from our childhood
that
warm our heart to this very day of
course
depending on how old you are those
things can
be a little different for some it is the
starting theme to a video game that they
worshipped as a kid
[Applause]
for others it's seeing a beloved
character from their youth
persevere and live on in other
franchises
[Applause]
he recovers german the tournament
and for the really young ones it's
probably
unforgettable gaming moments like this
still alive shots going down can't
connect with that one what bill's left
the final moments of fortnite oh my gosh
bow
down bow down to booga
doesn't even matter but there is one
childhood stable that has been able to
bridge that generational gap
by using a very special warm and
fuzzy brand of wholesome of course i'm
talking about
none other than bob ross the legendary
yet
long-past afro-sporting artist from the
80s and 90s
just sort of scrubbing man we don't care
this is your world
and you can do any old thing here so how
did a man who died
26 years ago becomes the most watched
art streamer on twitch what unforeseen
role did he play in shaping one of the
most
goosebump-inducing online trends ever
created
and why exactly has this soft-spoken
brush
magician who used to be on tv decades
ago
become one of gaming and modern pop
culture's
most recognizable and imitated
figures we don't we don't make mistakes
we have happy accidents
[Music]
hey guys it's dimitri now turning a
mistake into a
happy little cloud may not be easy but
you know what is switching to geico 15
minutes
could save you 15 or more on car
insurance
be sure to check out the link in the
description below for more info
alright now let's get back to the video
now if there's anything you need to know
about
bob ross it is that he was a man of many
contradictions
for starters he was born and lived the
majority of his life in a balmy
florida but painted mostly frigid
alaskan landscapes
which were inspired by the 12 years he
spent in america's
coldest state as a member of the u.s air
force
i was almost 20 years old before i ever
saw snow
and my favorite uncle uncle sam
he sent me up there in january
thought that would be funny it was funny
i i got off the plane the first thing i
did was stepped on the ice and
fell on my bottom as a man notorious for
having one of the most
mind-numbingly soothing voices in
existence
you'd never guess that for a chunk of
his 20 years in the military
bob ross was a drill sergeant who went
about his day
yelling at recruits to shape up a role
he grew
so tired of that when he left the air
force
bust him up bobby vowed never to scream
again put a little window in there
little one over here
now there's somebody at home as for
bob's iconic
afro not what his hair actually looked
like
while trying to get his painting venture
off the ground bob ross traded an
army standard crew cut for a permed
hairdo to save money on hair care and
sometimes
hair gets a little crazy you know look
at mine unfortunately for bob
by the time he was making enough money
to start getting regular haircuts again
the afro had become his trademark so he
had no choice
but to keep it for the rest of his life
he hated his hair
but it was his trademark and he had to
do it
and it really really bothered him
and possibly the single most ironic
thing about bob ross
is that he was known to be an immensely
positive man who
encouraged people the world over never
to doubt themselves
on this canvas you're the creator
anything that you want you can build
here this is your world
but when it came to painting other
humans
only one picture out of the thousands he
created on his pbs show
the joy of painting had a person in it
maybe bob ross wasn't actually that fond
of humanity after all
and you've heard me say this before i
hope you're plagued with dissatisfaction
as long as you live
but what bob ross was unquestionably
fond of
was nature he was a known lover of
animals trees and of course
happy little clouds using just the
corner of the brush
we'll put a happy little cloud in his tv
heyday mr ross was a true force for good
not only was he raising money for
various causes by
auctioning off his works he also
encouraged the average viewer to give
painting a try without feeling
intimidated by the prospect of failure
i'm trying to teach people a form of art
that anybody can do
this is art for anyone who's ever wanted
to put a dream on canvas
it's not something it's not traditional
art it's not fine art and i don't try to
tell anybody it is
for about 11 years bob ross was
without a doubt america's best known
and most loved painter next letter
comes from uh oh
martha you were to be shane for sending
that and we're gonna put that aside
that was a little too personal but in
1995
bob's doting fans and the rest of the
world
were left shocked and saddened when they
found out that he had succumbed to
lymphoma
at the age of 52. he really touched a
lot of people
and made a difference in their lives and
i think the painting made a difference
but
what he said made a difference just have
a good feeling and be happy and
in love with the life and your world and
sit down and begin playing
and if you feel good about yourself and
the world it'll show in your painting
and all these little things will happen
now for most tv personalities no matter
how
adored they might be that would pretty
much be the end of the road
but in bob's case it was only the
beginning
pbs had some interesting stats in terms
of how
viewers engaged with the joy of painting
even though the idea was that people
would
follow along with bob about 90 percent
of them
simply sat back and watched the program
why because of bob
i think sometimes we work too hard at
painting painting should always be fun
should make you happy bob ross's
deliberate movements and
gentle monotone manner of speaking
directly to the viewer
was literally mesmerizing people and
putting others to sleep in the best
sense of the word
viewers with insomnia claimed that the
joy of painting would finally help them
to doze off
or at the very least to relax
and this is where we come to the fairly
divisive trend that bob ross
inadvertently helped to father asmr
you know those videos of people
pretending to do your makeup
or like scratching their microphone for
an hour straight
well good old bob was basically an asm
artist way before the concept even
existed
just take a clean dry two inch brush and
i'm going to gently
gently tap following the angles in the
mountain
always follow your angles and even
though reruns of the joy of painting
continue to do well for pbs younger
generations were spending less and less
time watching tv
and more time online so in 2012
in an attempt to introduce bob to that
younger audience
pbs remixed some of his most iconic
quotes
into a youtube video that ended up
going viral let's build a happy little
cloud
let's build some happy little trees
and of course as millions of web
literate
teens began to discover the painting
legend for the first time
it was only inevitable that some pretty
dank bob
ross memes began to emerge i'm painting
happy little trees call me jackson
potter
because i spider m.c with the voices so
let's
do this i twist it up like you're a
rubik's cube
then in 2015 a full two decades after
his tragic
passing bob ross continued his ascent
into internet stardom
when he became the face of the new
creative section
on twitch for its launch the streaming
platform aired
every episode of the joy of painting
over the course of eight and a half days
a broadcast that had a steady average of
about
40 000 viewers the whole time that it
was live you could change your mind
right in midstream
there's no commitments in this anything
that you want
you can do in the end a whopping
5.6 million people had tuned in to watch
bob
paint happy little trees and twitch was
so impressed by these numbers
that they decided to make these streams
a weekly thing
now predictably it wasn't all sunshine
and rainbows in chat
even a stream as wholesome as bob's was
bound to have
a few knuckle draggers trying to ruin
everybody else's good time still the
stream was a resounding success
and to this day bob continues to be the
world's
number one most watched art channel on
twitch
complete with his own emotes and
spirited rounds of
ggs at the end of each broadcast and
it's not just the og stream itself that
attracts eyeballs no there are tons of
bob ross parodies and paint alongs out
there
that have amassed millions of views
stay tuned get ready and a
try your best that's all that matters a
few
little happy trees there nothing wrong
with making friends with trees
now what you don't want to do is eat
these paints
trust me on this one so imagine this is
martha this is me
this is our boy billy who i haven't seen
in 10 years god knows what he's doing
and that's my heart and this her keeping
my heart out she's going to rip out my
heart
uh it's going to hurt a little bit it's
going to hurt a lot but you know that's
just the name of the game that's love
that's relation hey that's life
why does he make trees look so easy and
so complicated for me
they look good uh yay
there's no such thing as mistakes just
just happy little accidents
so considering that a man who has been
dead for over a quarter of a century has
more online clout than most streamers of
today could ever hope to achieve
the obvious question is how does he do
it
what is it about bob ross that keeps
people of
all ages and all walks of life coming
back
time and time again to watch him do his
thing
is it simply nostalgia is it the memes
is it asmr the truth is that it's
probably all of these things and then
some in the last
year and a half bob's stream provided a
much
needed source of social connection in a
world
paralyzed by a pandemic i think
everybody
everybody should have a friend
friends are so important as basically
the prometheus of publicly broadcasted
painting
bob brought what many people consider to
be a high brow
elitist pastime to the average person
and his streams continue to carry that
torch for him
even now it's not so much that he wants
these to go in museums
he's trying to teach people how to do
his techniques
and there are plenty of people who try
his techniques and they work
and and it gives people that sort of
confidence
but on top of connecting us all and
de-snobifying a
beautiful primal form of self-expression
bob's veritable internet resurrection
turned him into a beacon of positivity
in a medium that is often severely
lacking in good vibes
and perhaps most importantly of all bob
ross
is the ultimate master of chill
something that all of us no matter what
generation we belong to
could definitely try to learn from dark
gotta have
opposites dark and light light and dark
continually in painting
if you have light on light you have
nothing if you have dark and dark
you basically have nothing
there we are you know it's like in life
it's got to have a little sadness once
in a while so you
you know when the good times come i'm
waiting on the good times now
[Music]
what about the str the prometheus of
publicly access
now because but museums are by
definition publicly accessible
you know what i mean though we can't
just call them the prometheus of art
like that's insane obviously like we
need to like quantify it
yeah he started art bro
like michelangelo who